please welcome Gary Vaynerchuk
good evening inbound
how are you I'm super excited to be here
so excited can we hear it one more time
for that that was [ __ ] remarkable
good [ __ ] I'm really excited about
tonight it's a very special day in our
amazing country and for me it's
especially special because I wasn't born
in the US I was born in the Soviet Union
I came here as a little boy both my
grandfather's spent substantial time in
jail just because they were Jewish and I
know that there's a lot of tension and
different beliefs about what should
happen tonight but the fact that we're
even able to vote and to be in this
amazing country is something that we
have lost perspective for and I'm very
thankful to be here tonight and to me
it's super interesting because I want to
talk about the journey of an
entrepreneur and by hands how many
people here are entrepreneurs raise your
hands
very nice and how many people here work
within organizations and our
entrepreneurial within them raise your
hands
very nice if we can keep these lights on
that would be huge for me if you don't
mind so for me I think the opening
statement is going to be this if you are
sitting in this room tonight and you
believe that whether Donald or Hillary
wins impacts you you're a [ __ ]
loser and I want to explain this we are
so lucky to be here in this playing
ground where the impact of the president
only has so much impact on you because
the reality is we are dramatically and I
mean dramatically more in control of our
lives than the media pounds down our
throats and so I hope if anything if
anything whether you're 16 or 97 and you
leave her tonight you
understand how unbelievable our
opportunity is to play in this ecosystem
what I want to talk about tonight is a
couple of things one we are living
through the greatest era of
communication change that we've lived
through since the printing press and
regardless of what you do in here it is
going to impact you tremendously over
the next decade because it's already
impacted so much over the last decade
and so for me that is a very important
thing but before I go into the tactics
that I want to bring to everybody so you
bring home something tangible I want to
start with something that I've been
spending a lot of time with and haven't
really expanded outside of the content
that I've put on the internet so on
stage tonight I thought a really
interesting thing to talk about would be
self-awareness if I could spend two to
three minutes with all of you and make
you understand that self-awareness is
probably the single most important thing
that you can spend time on for your
outcome for your future life it would be
so exciting to me if hundreds or
thousands of people left here today and
started really realizing who they
actually were we're living in an era and
we have forever where people have sold
us on the optics of what we should be
where we should go let me tell you a
story about myself it's really it's
really funny I got an email earlier
today or yesterday from a friend of mine
Jay that I went to college with who
works with Carolyn who I went to high
school with are you guys here can you
guys stand up can I find you get up
there they are can we clap it up for my
homies what's funny is both of them know
how bad of a student I really was and
what's really interesting to me on that
is both of them also know that for some
reason at a very young age I was
extremely self-aware I knew exactly who
I was and I was able to bet on my
strengths I think that when I think back
to my life and the story of my life and
what I really want to impose on others
to be able to navigate through is I was
lucky enough to have a mother who
instilled so much self-esteem into my
body I was able to navigate through the
universe of not worrying about what
everybody else thought about me and what
I've really to be very frank with
you I've come to realize over the last
year or so that I feel so much guilt
just general guilt that I had it so good
that a I came from nothing which is a
massive advantage can the immigrants
raise their hands in this room let's
clap it up for these people that have a
major advantage its we're lucky one
thing immigrants realizes how good it
really is so I had that I had nothing
and then I had a mom that did all the
right things for me and made me feel so
phenomenal and so basically I've come to
realize I've been asking myself over the
last year like why am i producing so
much content like what the [ __ ] am I
really doing here I've got this hundred
million dollar a year business to run
like why do I [ __ ] d-roc following me
around everywhere like what am I really
doing here and I've come to realize that
I have so much guilt inside of me for
having it so good that I want to use my
content that if I can play the role that
my mom played for me for anybody in this
room then then I've accomplished
anything that I could ever dream for
because look there's a lot of people
that are gonna make money but to me the
most important thing is how you make
your money not how much you make and
what I realize thanks mom and what I
realize what I realize is that we live
in an era now where we can all document
and create content around these
narratives and communicate in a
different world
the thing that I'm completely taken
aback by is the fact that this is now
the television and the television is now
the radio and it's the late 40s and
early 50s and the people in this room
that understand that and understand that
snapchat and YouTube and Facebook and
Instagram are ABC NBC ESPN and MTV and
you like that it's a good one right but
I'm not done yet you [ __ ] me up all
right
and that the businesses and individuals
in this room that realize how to make
mash or Seinfeld or the best shows on
those platforms will win we are living
through a major shift where every person
in this room has a binary decision
either you go on the defense because of
all of this or you go on the offense
either you realize this is the greatest
opportunity we've ever had as humans and
entrepreneurs or you're scared of all
these changes and you judge them and you
fear them and so for me in this huge
shift of technology and communication
comes the greatest opportunity ever
again
cuz the theme of the night for me the
fact that mainstream media has been able
to cast such a cloud over this ecosystem
is fascinating to me I'll be very honest
with you I'm not sad I'm not sad I'm
pumped I am thrilled that so many people
think it's bad cuz that's more
opportunity for me and so what I implore
you to do is spend a hell of a lot less
time worried about other things that
will impact you and spend a lot more
time to figure out who you actually are
what are you actually good at are you
actually in a position to be successful
what do you like doing because the
opportunities are endless the problem is
we are scared to do different things
because the fundamental core reality is
we worry about what other people think
we worry about getting judged if we fail
one thing that I've been very blessed
with is I've traveled the world quite a
bit for business and speaking and one
thing that a lot of people may not
understand is that entrepreneurship does
not work in a lot of other countries
because failure is a scarlet letter here
in the US we're so lucky that
entrepreneurship is met with when you
fail you pick yourself back up and you
go and to me that is unbelievable and we
are blessed to be in that ecosystem and
we need to take full advantage of it so
look
I like the back yes back step up this is
real [ __ ] [ __ ] we are [ __ ] like
can I ask you a question do you
understand that you're only gonna live
one time everybody has a lack of
perspective and reality of what's going
on here we have so much opportunity
you're in a [ __ ] Convention Centre in
Boston listening to [ __ ] Hamilton
wake the [ __ ] up [ __ ] seriously you have
it so bad
perspective is so ridiculous the only
thing I fear besides the health and
well-being of my family is regret the
thing I'm so scared of and one of the
tactics if I can inspire 20 people to do
this that would be big [ __ ] I'll take
one if one person in here can start
spending more time in a retirement home
go and donate your time your most
valuable thing and go spend time with 70
80 90 year olds do that for one day two
days a week or two and you will
understand very quickly that the only
thing that is scary is the things that
you didn't do right it's those things
and I sit here tonight and people are in
their tactics they're in their business
their startup they work in their
companies and the thing that I fear and
the thing that I'm passionate about
deploying tonight is really pushing a
little bit more what I would call
practical risk practical risk is
something that I've been thinking a lot
about a lot of people tell me they can't
take the chance of going and doing what
they want to do whether it's a different
job whether that's by the way I've done
a hundred emails in the last six months
of people that needed the courage to
shut down their startup and get a job
because they were worried about the
ramifications of being made fun of for
not executing on their business whatever
it is as you sit here tonight I want to
deploy and I want to start talking about
practical risk and what practical risk
means to me is the thing that I did not
understand until I started getting
thousands of emails a year from
individuals is we're [ __ ] fancy we're
[ __ ] fancy
it's not that you can't it's that you're
not willing to give up dumb [ __ ]
for a better life you're not willing to
go backwards you're not willing to make
yourself dramatically happier to move
out of your home and downsize and go
into a different neighborhood you're not
willing to go backwards that to me is
fascinating the fact that things were
their home car watch clothes going out
is holding people back from a
substantially happier life is
fascinating to me and something that we
need to debate because at the end of the
day that one at-bat is all we've got and
so if I can absolutely push you one
tangible item I see some people have
pads and pens and I'm fascinated by that
go ready go to a [ __ ] F uck ing
retirement home spend time collect data
realize regret is the worst and do
something about it got it awesome let's
clap it up for her I really want to talk
about the phone and Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat cuz it's a place
I come from and I want to get a little
bit away from the heady [ __ ] right now
and get a little bit back into
practicality if you are not producing
content on the five to six major social
network platforms today you are creating
an enormous vulnerability for whatever
you would like to happen in life the
person you want elected getting money
for your kids charity selling [ __ ]
communication has shifted forever and
these platforms really really matter the
problem is even at a conference like
this where there is so much marketing
skill I am flabbergasted by the lack of
practitioner ship in the actual creative
ability and paid media amplification of
creative to make a business action I for
a lot of you that don't know built my
family's liquor business really on the
back of Google AdWords Google AdWords
came out I bought the wot word wine for
five cents of
and even though I was doing direct mail
and doing local television and
billboards I get a lot of accolades in
this ecosystem from building my dad's
liquor store from a three to a sixty
million dollar business but the truth is
I stand here tonight and admit to you
not excitingly that it should have been
150 million dollars because if I
actually understood how unbelievable the
arbitrage was on Google AdWords I would
have spent a lot more money on it and
grew my business much more but I was too
patient I did well not enough I did not
go all-in and I built a nice business
but in reality I left a lot on the floor
tonight as we sit here tonight as we sit
here tonight the number one arbitrage in
marketing in the world and I don't give
a [ __ ] if you do b2b how many people in
b2b raise your hands
uh-huh I know you [ __ ] how many
people b2c uh-huh so even better I'm
going this is why I do this it allows me
to go in a certain direction
b2b clients for me at Vayner and the
startups that I'm involved with are
doing even better than b2c clients on
social specifically Facebook because
there's one amazing thing about b2b we
and I'm in it now with vaynermedia we
know the name of the customer we know
the businesses we want we even know the
decision maker we want the problem is we
suck we get real lazy and we send bulk
[ __ ] emails unlinked [ __ ] in can
we make a pledge tonight actually you
know what let's do this if you're
willing to pledge to no more bulk email
horseshit spec email on LinkedIn stand
up so I can clap for you personally make
a pledge let's let's wait get up more
[ __ ] this bulk email [ __ ] don't sit back
down dude with the beard get the [ __ ]
back up I see you I'm talking to you
yeah you there we go let's turn on
another minute on internet let's clap it
up for this pledge no more
enough thank you guys best part is the
[ __ ] doesn't work how many people here
have done email marketing in their
career raise your hands are you looking
for your seat Hey look for your seat god
how many people here have done bulk have
done email marketing in their careers
I'm just curious in 1997 I had a 200
thousand person email newsletter for
Wine Library & Wine Library calm that
had 91.3% open rates not because I was a
hero but because email marketing hadn't
existed yet the thing that I'm most
fascinated by is that I know as a
marketer and I'm a marketer as a
marketer the number one thing the thing
that I know more than the Sun will come
up tomorrow is that marketers ruin
everything it's what we do when I saw
that little [ __ ] ghost I'm gonna [ __ ]
up that ghost
I got you snapchat I'm gonna ruin the
[ __ ] out of this platform you show me
attention and I'll show you place that I
want to sell and that's how it gets
changed and bulk email in 2016 is
insanity nobody's opening that [ __ ] and
what just cuz you have an algorithm that
says hey Gary and by the way I saw ten
of these emails today all the [ __ ] in
this room that have the hey Gary thing
that's in a different font than the rest
of the email you suck right I mean
enough of that Jesus b2b I'm gonna go
tactical cuz I want to leave what I
wanna you know lately I've been trying
to get even more tactical in my keynotes
cuz I love the emails that I get where
hey thank you so much and help my
business here's the tactic I'm gonna
give you the best blueprint I have for
b2b selling right now and I really hope
it brings you some value and I'll go
into I'm going to go into a detail I'm
gonna get a little nerdy if you're gonna
be to beat environment you have to run
Facebook Ads and you have to do it now
they cost about five to six dollar
cp/m right now on average the cost of
these CPMs will be $30 36 months from
now I'm saying this because I know I'm
gonna have the video of this and in
three years you're going to see me share
this clip and be and I'm gonna tag it I
told you so [ __ ] it's gonna be
$30 a CPM because everybody's gonna
figure out how much attention is really
on that platform so the supply and
demand curve is gonna change just like
why now is a six $7 word got it okay so
now you're gonna run Facebook ads and
first and foremost you're not gonna
outsource it to somebody else you're not
gonna find little Suzy that's 23 in the
office be like you you're young you know
social media not gonna do that you're
gonna actually spend ten hours and read
and watch videos it's crazy you can
learn anything so many people like Gary
but I don't know how to use the
Instagram product I'm like I get it you
go to Google and you search it [ __ ]
okay that's what you do it's not super
complicated
it's crazy anything you don't know you
can search in two seconds
everybody's crippled like they don't
know it's [ __ ] there you do that and
so here you become a practitioner you
actually deploy the Facebook Ads
yourself so you have some ability and
knowledge so somebody can't hose you you
need to be the person that knows it the
best you then target there's a way to
target employees of at one more time
b2b raise your hands you guys know who
you're going after I want you to target
the employees of that company one by one
the employees now you take a step back
now you know you're targeting 15 17 22
different businesses if you want to get
really crazy you target them one by one
and you make videos or pictures just for
that company but if you want scale you
can put them all in a bucket and now
you're going to make a video or a
picture you know a billboard or print ad
or a television commercial and you're
gonna make it and what you're gonna do
is you're gonna make the creative start
with does your CFO know does your CTO
know
does your CIO know you know exactly who
in that organization in that
organization is the person that needs to
see that content and you're going to
start the video or your picture with
that statement and I promise you for
hundreds of dollars depending the size
your business sometimes for a thousands
of dollars that person is going to get
twelve to twenty five to a hundred
people forwarding them that piece of
content and that piece of content will
be the gateway drug to your sales team
to convert and clues it works every time
that's it right I can talk about you
like that right it's practical black and
white you got it right I can talk about
one life and all that [ __ ] but that's
[ __ ] up in the clouds right that's
like who gives a [ __ ] right yeah I care
okay that's one good next to the single
best arbitrage in marketing and I want
to take a step back I want to make sure
everybody understands III think the
slide was up there will end with a slide
I day trade attention I am NOT a
technologist I'm not a digital at this
not a [ __ ] blogger what the [ __ ] I'm
somebody who's obsessed with attention
from when I was six years old and
instead of standing behind the lemonade
stands I would sit and watch cars drive
by and figure out where to put the signs
I'm sick you know to now so I stand here
and actually say if you have the money
in I would say HubSpot if I ran the
marketing the number one thing that I
would do is run a Super Bowl commercial
I stand here today as a marketer that
trades attention and I believe that the
number one deal in marketing today is
actually a Super Bowl commercial it's
six million dollars but the entire
country whether they watch it on YouTube
or during the game will know exactly
what you're up to
now most people [ __ ] it up because they
try to mix up funny video for 30 seconds
and then we forget but that is to me the
number one play the number two play in
the world is
book video because I believe that
Facebook video not confined to 30
seconds has the ability to build
enormous awareness vaynermedia had a
very special thing happened last week I
don't know if any of you guys caught
this but when the Cubs won the World
Series
we ran who's from Chicago finally right
[ __ ] 108 when the Cubs won the World
Series we ran an ad and ad after the
World Series first it was Nike then it
was us and we brought back Harry Caray
from a classic 1984 commercial and that
went big and everybody said we were
geniuses and I got a lot of emails that
night and it was super awesome and I
replied to everyone saying wait until
tomorrow what tomorrow was was the next
day we deployed a two minute plus video
where Harry Caray we took 30 years of
him calling games and chopped it up and
had him over two-minute video call the
final out of the Cubs winning the World
Series that video has 30 million plus
views at this point and has drove a lot
more incremental growth and awareness
and b2b activity for the brand than the
commercial did though the commercial
media like buying the commercial and
making sure you all saw it cost
multiples 20-30 times more expensive
than what we deployed in a Facebook
environment this is what's happening my
friends I want you to become historians
of marketing I want you also understand
what marketing is we have confusion in
the marketplace of marketing and
branding versus sales we have a lot of
people in this room that are digital
natives and they really understand sales
they understand optimization ui/ux
they understand cost per click they
understand how you convert and change
things and things of that nature but
what they don't do is actually brand and
mark it and if your business is growing
you have to have a healthy balance of
marketing and sales and branding my
friends I did not buy these sneakers
because Nike [ __ ] cookie me and sent
me to some [ __ ] website and converted
me I bought it because of brand and
there's a lot of people here that are
mixing it
and the reason Facebook is so special is
it's the first platform that I've seen
that does marketing and brand and sales
in one place with underpriced attention
if you grew up in Google like I did
there was no brand there we all had blue
letters and bran was eliminated so if I
had one plea for the collective room
tonight from a marketing and branding
and business standpoint it is that we
have to understand the following and
this is tough for the digital landscape
but very easy for the Madison Avenue's
landscape creative is the variable
creative is the variable of success the
one thing that we all trade on in this
room no matter how and what you do
whether you're b2b or b2c whether you
sew sneakers or wine or books or your
services no matter what we are all tied
to attention we are all battling for
your attention but once you have my
attention that creative is the variable
if your video sucks [ __ ] I can give you
9,000 ideas on Facebook you will lose
and that to me is something that has to
be debated in this ecosystem much more
the other world I live in Madison Avenue
where they believe in commercials
they're the other way they just think
it's art if you understand and start
respecting both art and science math and
creative equally friction creating that
diamond you'll be a successful marketer
over the next decade the problem is we
usually fall into one camp or the other
so if you sit here tonight
please start understanding respecting
and building your skills around the one
that you don't actually do because
what's happening is we have unbelievably
overpriced attention and the other thing
that's happening is we have people that
lack self-awareness to know what they're
good at and what they're not good at and
when you start understanding those
variables you start actually making
results happen I'm blown away by the
world that I live in today for a lot of
you don't know I run a 750 person firm
called vaynermedia I'm leaving here
right now if there's taco in London we
just open a London office and what we do
is we work with the biggest brands in
the world
Under Armour and chase and Toyota and
Pepsi and the amount of money that is
wasted just just watch what I'm about to
show you and I think we can all agree
there's not this is not a
fourteen-year-old girl
crowd raise your hand if you now when
you watch television
fast-forward every single commercial or
watch Netflix or HBO GO if you when your
favorite show airs you don't watch one
of airs you watch it now on your time
raise your hands I just want everybody
look around keep them up especially from
row look at this let me just give you
the punchline everybody and how many
people here if they're still using DVR
TiVo fast-forward every single
commercial when given the option and so
even if something crazy like the remote
control falls off the bed every person
here grabs this anytime that there is a
commercial yet eighty billion dollars is
spent by the biggest brands in the world
to make 30-second videos of a jeep going
up a hill or some guy grabbing a beer or
some lady with a baby using some oil
eighty billion dollars it is completely
not practical it is broken and it is the
reason that 95 percent of the fortune
500 biggest brands in the world have
declined in market share over the last
two years here's what matters to
everybody in this room all that money
all that money is coming into our
ecosystem once they start calibrating
how bad it actually is when coca-cola
and BMW and the biggest buy BM start
taking that money from page 147 of
Sports Illustrated and from a commercial
of guiding light and they take those
dollars and they put them into Facebook
and Instagram the price of our attention
is going to go through the roof
so I sit here today and plea and I plea
that if you are not activating your
marketing in that ecosystem you are
going to miss the golden era of Facebook
marketing and you will regret it and
people run around here there are people
in this room that run around
here with an opinion on Facebook
marketing and they've never deployed a
single ad on it there are people here
that run around and have opinions on
Instagram marketing and have never
deployed a single penny on it period
also we sit here today in early November
2016 when the greatest marketing
arbitrage besides Facebook advertising
is influencer marketing you may not like
it you may not think it's cool that
people have detox T pictures in their
Instagram or that [ __ ] waste thing
that freaks me the [ __ ] out but it
doesn't take away the fact that right
now even in a b2b environment that if
you took the hours and map the people
that had 400 followers 500 followers I'm
gonna go back into practical details you
go into Instagram you go into search you
start searching hashtags for your
business fast right whatever your
industry is about and you start finding
people that post you start building a
database and then you email them one by
one with context we already made a
[ __ ] pledge don't break it already
and you ask them to promote your [ __ ]
and the price points are incredibly
under priced for the amount of attention
you get and the business development
opportunities yet we continue not to do
that meanwhile what's overpriced
Twitter's overpriced
it breaks my heart a lot of you guys
know that Twitter was my coming-out
party it is absolutely the platform that
put me on it's not fun for me to sit
here and say that it's overpriced but
the problem is Twitter has a firehose
problem there's so much and we don't
populate it it's just like email going
from 90% to 30% and that is a problem
and the ads are overpriced and that's
just an ecosystem so unfortunately for
them they're dealing with what we're
dealing with the other thing that's
overpriced is all programmatic
advertising banner ads are such a
mistake for businesses today because
there's nobody
you're going to the right side of daily
daily org and clicking a [ __ ] banner
ad and so we sit here tonight with an
ungodly amount of ridiculous marketing
tactics and looming ahead of us is so
much technology how many people here
have Alexa voice in her house
Alexa raise your hand stand up actually
let's get the blood going stand up I
need a context here has a Lexington home
yes I know you're on the screen you're
pumped all right it's [ __ ] awesome
right get up here with me very athletic
Jesus thank you man it's good to see it
good just chill right here just y'all I
know I'm aware yeah just sit I think
okay yeah no no you can do whatever [ __ ]
you want you're [ __ ] big boy I like
it do your thing all right man hey man
how are you it's me Jesus man you look
really young you look good all right I
mean that's good but this is way better
right
free advertising um when you start
thinking about Alexa and all these other
things one of the things that my career
has been completely predicated on is the
fact that I am willing to take chances
on things that aren't mainstream yet
because I understand that if I go after
social code and if I go after vine and
if I go after Mi'kmaq and if I go after
yak and if I go after all these things
that I only need one of those seven to
actually hit snapchat Instagram to win
that bet we have enormous fear in this
room too I have to wait or let's wait to
its big or what if I waste my time
awkward right yeah super awkward
you could leave if you want but you can
she'll - got it will I waste my time on
these platforms right will I waste my
time on these platforms if it doesn't
become big and so one of the other
themes that I really wanted to leave
here with tonight knowing the demo of
this room is we have to have a lot more
risk tolerance on new platforms if you
not playing back to details and I know
you're taking notes if you're not
playing with Marco Polo and after school
and house party then you're not there
potentially at the platforms that can
become the next things at the top of our
tongue how many people here let's be
really honest let's be really really
really honest with ourselves inbound
please raise your hand if this is true
how many people in this room and I want
everybody look around said two and a
half years ago three years ago maybe
even a year ago that they would never be
on snapchat that was stupid and now have
a snapchat account raise your hands
raise it high higher this this is where
all the action is this is where all the
action is this is the opportunity in
this room but we continue to downplay we
continue to downplay the upside cuz we
fear the risk of being on there and
wasting time if you have not achieved
what you want to professionally or in
life time is the number one thing you've
got you need to deploy as much of that
as humanly possible that is the asset
when you have not achieved the things
that you want to happen in life and it
is because of time that you ever wanted
to put into these platforms of worlds
that is a massive mistake it's the one
asset you have not everybody in this
room has money it's true you agree right
so are you gonna work your [ __ ] face
off thank you it's the one thing we have
it's the one thing we have because
everybody wants to come up with excuses
I'd spend my life reading excuses on
social media and my inbox on this I
wasn't born that way I wasn't born here
this a female I'm an immigrant I'm a
minority I'm a transgender I excuses
reality by the way I truly believe those
are disadvantages I'm not naive to the
shortcomings of this country the problem
is nobody cares the market doesn't care
so we sit and wait dwell and that's what
do you think we've been doing for the
last month and what we're gonna do
tomorrow morning we're gonna dwell and
complain and that's utter defense
instead of going on the offense and so
we spend unbelievable amounts of time do
selling and wasting our time on dumb
[ __ ] like people literally email me and
say you're so lucky and I wish this was
happening to me and then the third tweet
or the third Instagram post is awesome
Saturday stay at home and watch the
entire season a [ __ ] game of Thrones
we need to start understanding how big
this opportunity is because for
everybody in this room you will sit back
in 20-30 years and regret if you didn't
execute in this era and by the way I
don't want to hear that this is for 20
and 30 year olds 40 50 60 70 it's an
equal playing field if you're willing to
be a practitioner and understand the
ecosystem that I've been speaking about
tonight there's never been a better time
look it's very obvious these kind of
characters there's no respect for 20
year olds in the business world 20 years
ago when I came out but now because of
Technology there's a lot of
organizations that absolutely respect 20
and 30 year olds also what is happening
is I'm spending so much time with 40 to
60 year old executives who are dwelling
and are upset and tell me dumb [ __ ] like
but Gary I didn't grow up with this [ __ ]
neither did I Alice I was 20 before I
even was on a computer I didn't grow up
with this [ __ ] I figured it out and so I
sit there and see completely capable
operators that have made it happen for
the last 20 30 years being crippled by I
don't understand how snapchat works it's
so confusing
we're just filled with excuses we are
people are just losing their hunger and
then and then by the way let me get
really mad for two seconds with my fancy
rich friends
the thing that I'm completely blown away
by that I had no idea was going on
in capitalism and meritocracy is once
you get rich you actually try to spend
your dollars to create laws that allow
you not to work and still hold on to
your money 100% right
I mean I'm blown away by this you were
benefit you were benefited because in
your 20s to 60 for 40 years you grinded
and out
executed somebody and you were able to
make lots of money but now that you're
tired and you're finished and you're
older and don't want to put in the work
you don't want the next young buck to
come along and eat your lunch
that's not how capitalism works true
it's just not and so we have all these
trends and we have the great fortune of
living in an era where things have been
really good for a very long time and so
I walk around the world and I told my
wife Lizzie I'm like Lizzie listen to me
I don't care clearly because I was such
a [ __ ] student what the kids do at
school but please they can't be in
programs where we give away seventh
place trophies I have no idea who wins
the election tonight but we need to
[ __ ] banned seventh place trophies in
America and so we have all these macro
situations going on and not to mention
for a lot of people here under 30 you
haven't been in the game during an
economic downturn cuz things have been
very cushy for the last seven years
where if you're 23 years old and you
have an idea your company's miraculously
worth four million dollars and so we're
living in a very intriguing time and I
think that the passion and the angst and
the energy that I bring tonight are
predicated on a couple tried-and-true
things number one if you're not making
long-term decisions you will be
vulnerable the markets changing very
quickly and anybody who's looking for
short-term stuff gets short-term stuff
and then gets hurt in the long term
things like Airbnb guys
Airbnb shouldn't have been invented by
Brian and Joe Airbnb should have been
invented by Marriott but Marriott is
looking short-term and isn't creating
business models to put themselves out of
business
uber should have not been created by
Garrett and right they shouldn't they
should have not been created by Garrett
and Travis they should have been created
by the guy or girl that owned the most
medallions in New York City or by
Greyhound if you sit here tonight and
you're doing well you're in danger
because there's somebody young and
hungry that has the internet which is a
platform that creates a zero cost to get
into the game
that's coming after your [ __ ] so if you
don't do what I do which is wake up
every single morning every single
morning and try to put yourself out of
business somebody else is gonna do it
for you it is much more fun my friends
to put yourself out of business than
have somebody else do it for you and so
please if your cushy whose cushy raise
your hand if shits going real well Jesus
Christ
three people raised their hand I think
you need to shut down this [ __ ]
you're doing good awesome
what was that I was like you're doing
good yeah we're doing okay and I don't
he always so you've got to understand
the only thing that's interesting to me
and the only thing I have I always say
that basically my career is predicated
much more similar to Mariano Rivera than
anything else that I can think of if
you're a baseball fan he was a very good
closure for the New York Yankees where
basically his entire career was
predicated on one pitch he had one pitch
for 17 years and nobody could hit it and
that's basically my business career I've
got one pitch which is the following I
know what you're gonna do before you
know you're gonna do it it's the thing
that I was gifted with just like if you
can sing just like it's you I've always
had the intuition I was made fun of and
aggressively made fun of for launching a
website in 1996 because just like people
sit here and think that vine or snapchat
is a fad there's people in this room
that remember where the whole internet
was a fad but I bet on it and I built a
big business and then it was made fun of
because this thing called YouTube came
out and I took a chance on that because
I thought it was going to be big and
started a wine show and sat in front of
a camera and drank four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes and hundreds of thousands
of people watched it and then that
worked and then Twitter worked and I
invested in Twitter and Facebook and
things of that nature but I had so many
losses along the way one thing that's
never talked about with my genius career
was that I was on YouTube super early
but I left six months in and started
producing Wine Library TV exclusively on
viddler I was
wrong one thing that's not talked about
is that I thought that the biggest
startup in the world in 2010 was going
to be yo Bongo I was wrong and I
continue to be interested in being wrong
for the rest of my life because I am a
purebred entrepreneur because I'm not
scared of trying things and wasting my
valuable time because I want things and
most of all and this is the most of all
the whole thing I just genuinely don't
give a [ __ ] about what you think about
me balanced with I really care about
what everybody says about me and in that
friction I mean that you have to deploy
real ego and real humility around this
course because we live in that world but
if I can inspire anything in the time
that I was here today it's very simply
this please do me one favor I'm gonna
wrap it up with this and this matter so
much to me please whatever it takes call
your grandmother go to your
great-grandfather's burial spot go back
to the old country go to a shelter do
something do something that recalibrates
your perspective on what is actually
going on here we have never had it
better
my friends I'm gonna leave you with a
very interesting data point you guys
like data
who likes data great let me give you
some [ __ ] data more people in America
will die from a coconut falling out of a
tree and hitting you on the head and
killing you then terrorism yeah
I see you tentative like is he [ __ ]
serious I'm dead [ __ ] serious kids 7
to 11 watch more twitch eSports than all
the four major sports combined that's
data we were living through a totally
different time 10 years ago the weirdest
thing in the world was your friend dated
people online now every single person
swipes to the left and right 24/7 and so
the trends and our society have changed
and either you're gonna sit here and
binary this is a black and white
conversation either you're gonna leave
here and understand how [ __ ] awesome
it is and you're gonna take full
advantage of it and be a winner
or you're gonna sit and dwell on all the
negatives of it and be a losing player
it's just the truth it's not complicated
it's not fun for me to say I don't want
you to lose I desperately want you to
win but this is on you nobody else is in
control there are people who deal with
things like the loss of their children
or real diseases we're sitting and
dwelling about not getting enough likes
on [ __ ] Instagram we're sitting and
dwelling about forces that don't really
have impact on us it is time that this
collective room and our space
understands this is the greatest golden
era of not only business but life and
your really and I mean really need to
[ __ ] grab it thank you thank you
you